it was played by Eugene O'Neill I think
whether it's men and women are meeting
they're falling in love with each other
and they're planning to get married
and he says that he says I know I need
to tell you something here because I'm
wearing a mask
she says you are she's well take it off
he's so I can't take it off if I took it
off you'd leave me she's but don't you
understand now that I know you're
wearing a mask if you don't take it off
we don't have a real relationship so in
a fundamental and a moment of
existential courage he lowers the mask
she sees his true face when she leaves
them put some ass back she comes back
like a mask wearing a mask but what true
love is this true love is this I think
this is married love or intimacy uh
you're wearing a mask I'm afraid to take
it off see all right
and so the other person says you know
don't I don't want you to take it off
until you're ready to take it off yeah
because I love you matter of fact let me
adjust it for you a little bit that's
right and the more you're accepted and
knowing that you're wearing the mask the
master is becoming translucent and your
face shines with the mask and real love
is offering that to each other a lot of
psychotherapies about this too yes I
think seriously safety really yes you're
convinced that you are what's wrong with
you yes